on a choisi de parler de grégory
lemarchal il ya un peu plus de 12 ans le
30 avril 2007 grégory lemarchal nous
quitter à seulement 23 ans des suites de
la mucoviscidose et hier on a pris une
grosse nouvelle tf1 prépare un biopic
sur son histoire
c'est anne viol la directrice artistique
de tf1 qui l'a révélée dans le parisien
il s'agirait de retracer l'histoire du
jeune chanteur dans son combat contre la
maladie nous faire entrer dans les
coulisses de la star ac on ne sait pas
encore qui sera l'acteur qui incarnera
grégory lemarchal
mais les premières rumeurs disent que ce
sera clément rien ce qui joue ma tin
dans demain nous appartient qui a
remporté danse avec les stars
voilà qui va jouer dans un truc en ce
moment alors est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une bonne idée ce que vous prenez
que ça va marcher ou pas sûr que ça va
marcher parce que les gens étaient
extrêmement attachés à ce garçon là tous
regardés on l'a tous vu on a tous suivi
on l'a tous aimé on a tous été très ému
par sa disparition
et il est encore au coeur des français
donc je sens que ça va marcher les
américains savent très bien faire ça
pour moi c'est le plus grand gagnant de
la série sur wii mais alors et on se
rappelle de pas mal de moments cultes
avec lui on se souvient de sa magnifique
reprise de sos d'un terrien en détresse
ou remplis de sawgrass qu'elle est
foutue des frissons à tout le monde
regardez
[Musique]
elin
jeune dans ma peau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mourad sur tf1 oui et c'est un projet
que tf1 a depuis plusieurs années parce
qu'il avait essayé de le lancer je crois
en 2015 2016 était déjà en train d'y
réfléchir
là ils veulent le faire coïncider avec
les 10 l'anniversaire entre guillemets
des douze ans de la disparition de
grégory lemarchal est ce que moi je
pense intéressant et ce pour quoi je
suis d'accord avec valérie dans le fait
que ça risque de très bien marché c'est
que beaucoup se rappellent de grégory
lemarchal danse qu'il a symbolisé dans
la lutte contre la maladie a toujours
monter sur scène les concerts alors
qu'il serait de la mucoviscidose pardon
mais le biopic ne sera pas recentré que
sur ça il fallait montrer des moments
très heureux apparemment c'était
quelqu'un de très drôle très joyeux et
vont aussi mettre l'accent
justement on parle d'un scénario joyeux
et ce serait bien aussi de montrer tout
le courage qu'avait ce supporter qui
braquent s'est passé parce que par
exemple pour cette prestation là il
faisait les piquouse pour qu'il soit au
top de sa forme voilà c'est sérieux un
magnifique exemple de courant il avait
remporté bien sûr cette édition de la
star ac
on revoit sarsgaard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la star academy 4 été
remporter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici
puisse faire ce soir
vivre pour le meilleur
[Applaudissements]
etc
[Musique]
appris que les académiciens de la saison
4 ce qui était avec lui donc l'instinct
qui allait se réunir pour soutenir
l'association grégory lemarchal et ils
ont faim ils ont fait un single hommage
pour grégory boîte